there's a long message 27 January 2013
at 16 17 it is st. from river to you
that was also part of the inners could
you read that out and then explain that
the message she sent me SIDS said I'm
not one hundred percent sure why I'm
sitting down to type you a message first
but perhaps it says a lot about what's
going on here so it was one of my best
friend's engagements and I wanted to
stay longer and I was enjoying myself
but it's over now you have picked me
picked on me incessantly since you got
back from Cape Town and I understand
that you were sick but it's nasty I was
not flirting with anyone today I feel
sick that you suggested that and that
you made a scene at the table and made
us leave early I'm terribly disappointed
in how the day ended and how you left me
we are living in a double standard
relationship where you can be mad about
our I feel about how I deal with stuff
when you're very quick to air cold and
offish when you are unhappy every five
seconds I hear how you dated another
chick you really have dated a lot of
people yet you get upset if I mentioned
just a bigger part
you have to get upset if I mention one
funny story with the longtime boyfriend
I do everything to make you happy and to
not say anything to rock the boat with
you you do everything to throw tantrums
in front of people you have been upset
but I have been upset by you for two
days now I'm so upset i left aaron's
party early so upset i can't get that
day back I'm scared of you sometimes and
how you snap at me and of how you will
react to mean that from the outside I
think it looks like we are a struggle
and maybe that's what we are I just want
to love and be loved be happy and make
someone so happy maybe we can't do that
for each other because right now I know
you aren't happy and I certainly very
unhappy and said I trust the background
to that mystery stories my lady we were
at Sur the background we were at an
engagement party of mr. frescoes I just
think of was it a bad day an hour no
relationship